she's special she really is man she's
like gonna win
let me help like you're gonna win like
form it like honestly you know what's
running through my mind right now
straight up I'm like I'm so happy I have
that on film
cuz one day you're gonna be the biggest
star in the world and I'm just gonna
keep putting out the clip when you're
like wow he's the best I'm so excited
right now how are you no worries I'm
super flattered get in here I'm so
excited for this meeting yes anyway
there's plenty seats for everybody um
I'm glad you came up what are you coming
up anyway today your work you're going
to be a ridiculously big star it's super
weird like you know it's great you know
what's crazy for me this is now
happening to me mainly in hip-hop like
like that uber email you see over there
right the the Sox Twitter Tumblr like
what I wrote about in my first book
about like social media it's so crazy I
didn't know that I feel like now I have
one core talent which is like I can see
it and like it used to be about like
trends or like companies and now I've
been really focused for about a year
hard on like hip hop and like it's
really actually honestly Mike really
helps me but not everything like I think
like there's a lot of things that I see
they'll be wrong or like I will [ __ ]
with something that becomes enormous but
some stuff is just black and white
obvious to me yeah man I really think
you I'm really excited for you and
what's interesting is I haven't I lived
like nobody being on Twitter like I was
on YouTube when nobody was like there
was not one video that had a million
views on YouTube when I started like and
so I've watched people like never saying
the word social media or YouTube or
Twitter so that's been cool right and I
did it with wine which is way less cool
like with like news
in wine in South African wine but I
never done it with people and now I'm
doing it with people so now I'm like
ma'am what would would it be like if I
was doing this six years ago and like
the weekend was just sitting here right
I'm like that's gonna be a weird feeling
right anyway none of us I I'm so
intrigued by your talent I was so pumped
when you hit me back and were like we're
fan it's so crazy right like I know
what's happening like I don't get ahead
of myself but I'm like wow if you
would've ever told me I mean yeah
they're saying I'm 42 like if you would
have told me
thirteen fifteen months ago eighteen
months ago that my cosine would mean
anything in any shape funny for me it's
like a book it's an out-of-body
experience really so what's going on
what's going on I'm just like I'm scared
to bring like I have like I think of
ideas like every second of the game
that's me too like they help me really
to just cataract just balance it and you
know just like give me like some type of
direction and of course just organizing
like the things in my head so like it
was our idea to just like put together
like well to try to put the way I feel
and to music of course cuz that's what I
do tell me more about yourself for
yourself I was born in Philadelphia
well part North yeah so it's kind of
like if they're trying to make it good
now they had my temple is taking over
everything I know I know
things that I saw when I was younger
it's not there anymore so but the
nice-ass building now so but yeah so it
was not as nice of a building when you
were growing singing my mom did she took
care of me you have siblings
yes I have a younger brother named
younger sister royal five years apart so
I'm kind of like setting like the tone
like I'm doing good and they have to
follow right along standards so yeah and
what did you know you were music down oh
well really like I kind of always just
loved like at first I wanted to be a
dancer then I was like I was singing a
little bit then Mike got me in church so
I was like okay I really like this but
then we got I got in school I forgot
what grade it was but we got introduced
to poetry and it was like we had to get
up in front of the class this was like
the first time we can't get up and
present and all of my friends we were
stolen I was there but see no horse and
it was just I think it's called
freestyle poem or like spoken word or
something that was like the specific
thing that we had to do and she was like
you know you just get up here and just
express yourself it has to be a page
long whatever and everybody did I was
the last to go up because my last name
is always on the roster because it's wet
so you know surely my exact story sixth
grade I don't give a speech in class
yeah and I went last I don't [ __ ] be
nervous the whole time and I wasn't the
public speaker I am today cuz I had to
like talk about [ __ ] I didn't care about
right wasn't as cool as what you did I
had a like you know like
nonetheless so I know yeah so like I
didn't know like poetry at first I liked
the fact like my mom
I have a cat in the hat' dr. Seuss yeah
once it's two things right yeah but you
know but like I just like certain poems
they just don't make any sense to me but
I just love the fact I'm just like that
you can rhyme any word that you
we of course it has to rhyme but we just
put words together I just love that I'm
so fast right from the beginning yeah
from the beginning and so you dinner
thing yeah I know I know we're really
well yes like right out the gate like
the kids in class is just like you know
you gotta like turn it into right do
right do right do rap time just like
what I just you know like but I like the
attention because for a while yeah yeah
oh my god I just like went to a thing
right I was getting teased and
everything like just I never got some
love yeah yeah so I got to composition
composition books and I like monk to
like I just had like every day I was
coming to school lunch anyone kill we
were I had like I was controlling like
everything like everybody get ready to
get their lines in at the table and I'm
just spitting these reps just like poems
but they were turning into reps and it
just went crazy and then you know how
long you really that that was like we're
in high school yeah okay nonetheless now
I got the picture yes so and then what
happened so then after that I just kind
of like so the composition was really
just help me to like because I had to
make my mom Gong she's I want these
books where you have to look like no I
want to write poems and then you know
like she starts saying how thick they
were getting and how I kept going back
side also to get new books that she's
like oh okay you're onto something so
that I had an uncle um you know I guess
you told him or something like this
whatever you know you need to family and
of course what are you doing it's just
like oh she's in the Tucci writes and
I'm so then he was like oh just right
over a beat and you can talk about stuff
that you know like the street scene you
know so I went up and I looked at like
the most gangster rappers and I started
talking about stuff like you know
don't say some of this stuff but I found
away does that literally go my mind
thinks you know going you know I was
just I went through that phase I'm just
just trying to figure out like I want to
be cool to like the hood because that's
where I was letting the horse you know
like that's what I'm going to talk about
but really I wouldn't everybody swears
to [ __ ] with them yeah right yeah but
then it's like so I wasn't the whole
thing I'm just trying to like you know
conform yes yes it was so I was like
people wouldn't really call me weird
yeah but you know you got so lucky
because if you were coming up I did a
different era that would have been the
only option this is the best time to be
able pop ever cuz it's a mature state
like you know it's funny I've seen the
exchange between you and yachty and I
always use him as an example of this
exact point which is that if Yanni came
out like that and nineteen that when I
was growing up even got his ass crazy to
me that like that like ice cube and
Arkell had sex and made the cut in the
new age rapper 20 that's what would have
happened 20 years ago I would have never
believed it but it's so amazing that you
can be your authentic self a female with
your angle on things and it's like hi uh
so it's why I wish people understood
hip-hop better like it's it's gone from
really not accepting like in a lot of
ways in my opinion to unbelievably
accepting in its current form at some
point she was like I'm not just rapping
a rat now I want to be
Artie yeah so that happened that was
like so middle school heaven which is
poetry poetry and then I went to high
school and then I started just this
random thing like just going in high
school like my first year ninth grade oh
yeah my mom was she's driving
we wouldn't visit my grandma ever has
been immersed in peace um we were
driving down like North Philly same
thing and she was like look and then I
look up and sometimes like a chair the
other day I didn't want it like be out I
had homework projects I was stressed out
it was just like was that great ear I'm
just like yeah so so what happened oh so
I look to my right and I see a big group
of guys at some corner just wrap and I
see like a nice camera like that that
was like you know it's beautiful like
yeah yeah nobody spoke I got it okay you
know yeah so kind of looks like a
special you know but I'm still kind of
like in my movie and then she's like you
should get out a red what I can't just
do that what do you mean and she's like
no get out of red something like so she
gets she knows me she can tell that I'm
thinking and I'm just like and she's
armed something i want to some of the
block so she circles black I mean think
about all the rapes that I have my head
and then I get out what do you call me
together cuz then they just call me two
dozen I'm like just neighborhood stuff
like whatever so that's just the person
that I thought up so I'm like so I'm
like like they were looking like I'm not
really feeling this and then this one
guy he's not here rest in peace he just
put his arm around me he was like no but
like she's high like y'all gotta listen
so I guess he ran a whole block so one
thing like cuz they were kind of like
that got away a little bit like she come
here she's talking about Dookie and
booties and just weird never like he saw
it yeah he saw it and and he was he
could he literally did you can see the
video you still finding video on YouTube
yeah yeah oh that's cool yeah I want to
see that bad
I did oh and dominated by the way go
watch it
I completely annihilated that show okay
so so he's like I'm wracking when I'm
rocking winter and then that's when I
found out like cuz I got the kind of
information from the dude who was hold
the camera and he had been like a
popular like blog and you know you know
like good West Hayes but everybody it's
called you in the streets that's what
it's called you know so like the rag was
like Meek Mill coming up redial there's
like all the data records were coming up
you know on his platform yet whatever so
I was like oh my god I can't believe I
got was it was just so good then since I
can't sure didn't want to put it up
tonight you see the feedback and then
I'm like one night six six thousand
views then like a week it was like
twelve salad and just kept jumping like
so good and he's like you know you
didn't have any buzz and like this is
going crazy and of course it's like
fifteen-year-old jumps out and blesses
the camera with our mom in the car or
something like that like the whole thing
and so after that meet tweeted me like
Osmocote all the big people all the big
heads from Philly just like we're
tweeting me and I'm just like no this is
not happening like I just couldn't
believe it and then everybody in school
was like that wait yeah but see the
thing was like you know that was just so
random you know me just not even wanting
to be outside and you know be in that
car like and then it just was just like
spinning school I was a problem my
principal she thought she hated me I
know she did I just got controlled
everything like whatever I said like it
just went like you know like just
whatever but you had too much juice yeah
and so then like you know this was going
on there
show us freestyling freestyling but I
got tired that like I was I was going
into the studio sessions and just
ranking over beats that you know weren't
original just like kills but I mean of
course I'm just trying to get a bus so
I'm doing what I horse I got so honing
your craft are getting exposure you
going through the process exactly so but
it just like I told you short assets in
that space so I just got worn really
fast good to me so I own I just was like
I wasn't feeling it like people were
calling like signing stuff or whatever
meek was trying to figure something out
I'm just like I'm not really I have been
in sessions and everything I'm just like
I don't know I don't want to dis restart
like my whole life you know II mean
since every time I was try to even just
different you know into like something
original like everyone's like no just
just kill some beaches kill some old
school beats I'm like that's cool but I
don't like I'm starting to get stressed
out and you know I was the only person
that really understood me was like my
mom like I was telling my friends like
what do you mean you have those hottest
people calling you and just do what they
want you to do want somebody said that
to me I was just like God now I can't do
this so me going through that and then
this was like um eleventh grade year
yeah this was like all happening it's
like 10 9th 10th 11th it's like
everything was like happening for me and
so my mom was like you know I'm thinking
about moving like I want something new
whatever and then I was like I need
something new and that's when we moved
to Georgia yeah you went you moved to
Georgia for your senior year so I stayed
there with her for about two and a half
years like almost three years and I just
kind of deleted social media this is
when I was going back different any
those little bids whatever and doing
social media I just was just trying to
find myself
yeah I mean like I figure it out and um
well when I went this fight is when i
went down to georgia people ever knew I
was in school like so I that's how I
knew that it was like serious an
affiliate everybody knows who I am but
when I went to Georgia and seen like oh
that's the girl like they every I was a
woman in a hallway that's the girl
that's the girl I just
I thought I was going to get away from
him but I'm still in it and so but
eventually I got my first job my it was
a car I worked at a car wash mr. hotshot
and I wasn't making so much money so in
fact tips were [ __ ] great I didn't
even care about my tag line just like my
tips we're so crazy and I was the only
girl like everybody else was like yeah I
just got out of jail
all guys killer like [ __ ] everybody
was crazy there but I was the only girl
and I was just getting tips so good I
love that job but I thought was too long
I wanted to save up for it my first my
laptop and I'm like that's what I want
to do so um so yeah I worked that job
got my back talked about Mike I'm still
learning myself and I was finding little
DS nerve because I still I could use my
buzz a little bit to like you know reach
out to start people like you know
blooper news enough and yeah we just
started like start doing some original
stuff and like I just kept it to myself
on their laptop and then when I felt
like I was starting to get it cuz I was
like I changed my name I'm gonna use my
real names here or wax like I just think
I was making a master plan they just
trying to just reinvent myself so like
being patient
yes but that it was so it's just it was
so much like pressure because everybody
in my corner was telling me you like
they didn't want me to do what I did
anyone take that's when you know it's
right yeah you know and I get it yeah
and so um so like a year and a half
almost two years went by whatever and I
was still just recording on the laptop
and I started just so confident but I
didn't show anybody any of my music so
that's kind of crazy to just you know
not like I had to just keep this like to
myself you already taste of the other
version yeah exactly you didn't have
impatience that everybody else had you
were ready in a place where everybody
heard everything you were doing so yeah
it was easier for you and a lot of ways
to keep it to yourself
cuz you knew what the alternative was
yeah you then you've gotten the the
digital exposure you've got radio
station exchanger it's okay so keep
going so that's what I called this guy
can eat so when I was he does like that
I used to have around studio sessions
all over Philly Philly trying to just
find that wet engineer yeah oh you just
until it feels right this guy's really
he's like really hard to like get
connects with like he's like a caveman
like you have to really be like good or
like just something special about you so
that's why I know that I'm special
like he reminds me um like I call it I
got in touch with him because I remember
I had so many sessions I had this one
session and it was of course with him
and I got one really good original song
done out of all the [ __ ] sessions
that game it was so [ __ ] many I
always do free stuff sweet stuff for
style I wouldn't studio with him and he
was like yo you can do original if you
want I was like what like that was like
the first engineer that had anything
like that in Philly for me and I'm just
like so you don't mind if I like you
know you I can work on the original
something's like yeah you can do
whatever you want to do so I always
remember that I said keep in mind I'm
still in Georgia thinking about my
something plan like so I connected with
him Instagram like oh I got some new
stuff I really need you know an ear or
whatever like like I said kept in mind
I'm sorry I'm like I'm pretending show
up saying you're not losing me at all
just become slow yeah it feels in slow
motion just so you know where you're
sitting this is a slow motion yeah so I
always kept him in mind but I knew he
was hard to get in constantly so I had
to make sure before I physically moves
back to Philly that I had him on lock
like I had my god he's the first person
I want to see what I could fill you so
he could be right back he's like what
everybody's been asking where minutes
for two years yes this is I need like as
an artist if you have an engineer in the
studio you can do anything under shame
so I got that with him plating the stuff
and I was came up to Kelly yeah oh yeah
back yeah that was that so your
Grandmama's past no not that way well
the wife is still alive she's got
respect
yeah okay
going in the wax so and you go play to
him you're nervous you're a goes well
yes what happened if he loves it he
loves it like now what is this like
quinoa who she was at that point because
I'm like okay I started calling her a
new zoo and she had changed her name to
Tierra Cory so she would she's like I'm
wet yeah oh man and not slip up cause
I'm close to calling the horses yes she
always liked it but she said to to meet
you I was like she like what you think
easy way different morning that you were
going for it and what happens next
I don't wanna say it's drag but like
it's just like we just started working
he was like yeah you could record here
whenever you want like he literally like
moved his sessions over and like just
let me so you crane the project yeah
yeah and what happened when did what
happen no no no no there is no project I
thought of these years he just like he's
like yo you can come in any show because
I started teaching you yeah he started
teaching me how to report on the better
he was like you know I'll lock out of
time you could just go ahead and
literally leave me in studio and just
let me just clarify one of my laptop so
I wasn't gonna change me into it yep
which was the best plan ever and then um
you know we just like I just touched in
so many dramas because he just gave me
that like the planning of it yeah
Doritos always like this
dude you are yeah that's what you do
with talent yeah yeah you don't box it
in yeah wasn't like now you got to do
this or you make this it was like she
said like you know yeah like yeah yeah
so and then like I don't know it's just
like that's really like the that's it
yes yes sort of the gist
what happened was like I know myself
like I don't like I'm not good at being
in the forefront and I know that like
sometimes you can mess up somebody
else's situation by not acknowledging
what it is that you are self-awareness
is the leverage maybe right so I'm like
yeah you won't manage me I'm like nah
yeah like I can I find care news isn't
that but yeah like Johnny's good with
business I'm not like oh my god for some
text it yeah I got it yes so it became
and it became all yeah and when was that
around that same time yeah by the same
time yeah and so what's been happening
for the last three years then yeah
that's that's really what it is like you
just like knowing the right time to just
like just like you know like drop here
in here just like when you won the
talent you have the leverage your moment
doesn't pass when you're good like
people are so confused
[Music]
[Music]
how's he should coach pace doing this
thing yeah everyone's watching yeah I'd
be here by now yeah what do you feel
when you drop the music video right now
was the time like like for what so now
is the time cool like this my whole
point like this is what all I've ever
heard for the last 10 years of my life
is now is the time I wrote this now is
the time
now now it's not the better question to
your point in the way you're looking at
it that's right but I think the much
more interesting question is do you at
this moment have a sense of what you
want to happen and if you don't then
it's just to continue to create right so
like for me like TB was always the time
TB I was like everybody was like this is
the time is the time and I didn't know
what I wanted and then when Apple came
along with a show where it had three big
celebrities and then me I knew that it
wasn't gonna be a big show because I
knew nobody had Apple TV like that
I just knew me positioned with those
three incredible celebrities that were a
list for the group that wouldn't know
about it cuz I knew I could meet people
know about it wasn't even like about you
know like I just wanted like just being
with Jessica will.i.am and Gwyneth
Paltrow for Hollywood put me on a
different sphere it didn't matter what
happened next that was the right time
and so for me was a huge win even though
it didn't become Shark Tank or American
Idol it was a b2b it was an industry it
was the people that like I'm in a
different mindset for a lot of people on
a different level for different people
not that I need that because I'd much
rather have three million followers on
Instagram than be on a TV show I needed
it for the leverage of other [ __ ] I may
want to do got it so you're in it
already when people that matter are
liking your content here you come along
you discover it or we're looking at it
from a different way you know and you go
and look well then she's already won
that narrative like one when people go
on mind so we're gonna see the rock
liked it you know like right so for me
there's a different thing which is the
different and right question for me is
what do you want to happen next
just like what the process kind of oh
just like you can tell me anything you
want no that's some real weird [ __ ] I've
just kind of been a space where like I
don't give a [ __ ] like I just don't like
I just can't like I can't afford to care
because sometimes of course when you
care you overthinking think too much and
it's just like something drive you so
crazy
you know what's crazy you don't give a
[ __ ] and you don't care because you've
hit full maximum caring oh that's
perfect that's perfect that's perfect
yeah that's exactly what it is it is
just like I'm just kind of just whatever
comes to my table and like to my plate
I'm just kind of like I think one thing
I'm listening to you very carefully and
I've been really listening to you
carefully in a different way and now
listening here I think the only thing
you need to decide is the so your your
stuff is so right it's scary
which is why all this is happening your
stuff the only conversations the three
four or five of you should be having is
in the short term where do we put that
stuff so when I hear what you're up to
like in what you want to do next I'm
like that's exactly right
because that's where you want to put
your stuff got it like that's what I
feel everything I do is gonna be right I
just have to decide where I want to put
it and sometimes I want to put in a
paper cup and sometimes I want to put it
filling an entire room you're gonna
always be right creatively you just need
to think about the context of the
distribution and what you want to happen
they are one of the reasons why Sheila
doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything
anymore I'm like what you were just
saying before it's like she doesn't
notice all these outside things because
like the public victory is about to come
but she's just had so much like personal
victory like she's had so many like
wings like on the inside everything
she's just like isn't ever thinking
about everything else and now she's
needs again my man I don't know anything
that anybody's doing yeah people ask me
[ __ ] all that I know what's going on
through other people's eyes yeah I know
what's going on in the streets cuz I can
see it through scale through his eyes
and through the feedback I get yeah
right like I spend time with you guys
cuz I can almost like weirdly like it's
so weird like I don't even like talking
about how I learn like I feel like it's
not some like weird superhero movie [ __ ]
you guys come in here and I like take it
like it's so weird how I do it which is
means I don't know what anybody's doing
I don't know about anything yeah I know
what it feels like to be in your own
little cocoon what I do think you need
to do what I do think the vulnerability
to our system is is where you put it and
why like you can't get over so a couple
things that are cliche for people that
are artists like you you need to be
careful to become too romantic about
your truth let me explain what starts
happening after a while is you manifest
into realizing how pure it is and then
the only thing you care about is the
purity of the pure and you become a
character sure of yourself your biggest
vulnerability is you becoming a
caricature of your truth because you're
so right and what happens after a piece
like after a while is you're almost
subconsciously biased becoming too
artistic so so what you need to do
it's super obvious c'mere right that's
that's your only vulnerability
otherwise you'll win which which leave
me - why Micro things matter this book
matters to me because it's a micro thing
like I here's how it works for me
this isn't about the money this is about
a lot of people learn from books like
people can watch every video listen
every podcast but for some [ __ ]
reason books I guess it's all gathered
in one place I don't learn from reading
so I don't understand it but other
people really learned from reading
taking all the notes right like not a
people I can take this book in circle
and highlight and put post-its and
that's how they learn and for me I'm
obsessed with the legacy of changing the
game for people and so all manifests
this but is this it does this represent
me is this Mike no this is a micro thing
and where it can get confusing
especially at this young of an age is
everything starts feeling macro and you
don't understand what macro and micro is
and all of a sudden you never put
anything out and you become dr. Dre and
all those years promising now who's
coming you get to macro doubt that's
what happened in in that moment but he
won and beats by dre and he's an icon
and there's a because the truth always
wins
if you're great there's nothing you can
do to stop it but the key is you start
getting into that yeah like you should
put out a project and if it doesn't do
well it's not gonna matter like all the
equity you get into a place where
everything that you've done that's been
so right for the last seven eight years
you think that output determines like it
has it has a lot of pressure behind it
because you haven't done it like it gets
over thought and it gets too precious
and then the timings never right and
then just becomes like this thing and
that's how special people use why do
special people that deserve to win
bigger lose
because of everything I just described
your last six minutes you've got to be
comfortable with micro and macro it's
not selling out it's not putting it all
on the line it's getting into the habit
of I do a lot of micro things like my
sneaker that was a micro thing I did a
collaboration caseless I thought it was
cool it was good at it it could have
been a disaster and I think when you
come from the right place you can't [ __ ]
it up you have to think about that if I
figured it would that's why I wanted to
listen way longer than normal because I
because I felt there was a whole lot in
you and like I was right you need to
embrace the micro cuz you're so macro it
out right that micro gets scary
there's so many things that so many
all-time greats did that were wrong that
nobody nobody remembers what the Beatles
did wrong there's a lot of wack [ __ ]
songs out of jay-z's mouth what people
understand is the winds outweigh the
losses and if you've met and you've got
it like that it's like with who
it's it's how it works right
when I say Lauren Hill you're not
thinking about the nine hundred things
that are wrong you're thinking about the
[ __ ] greatest album that maybe that's
what you have to figure out got it and
you know where it comes from and you'll
love this it comes from humility I think
what makes you special is you have it I
don't think I think might not get I
don't know I'm going on some good
intuition I think you need to harness it
because when you harness your humility
it is your strength but when you harness
it it makes you realize that the reason
I'm right is because nobody gives a [ __ ]
enough about you
so crazy yeah it's crazy it's right it's
what it's what it feels like when it
makes so much I can just see it it's as
clear as day for me what's going on with
you doesn't mean you doesn't mean you
need to sign but you should put out you
know I always say put out more stuff
everybody's got the reasons and versions
but it's always the right answer you
just got too much in you to like not put
it out and you're just putting too much
romance around the narrative and you've
gotten you've been so good at being the
architect behind it that your pride sits
within it like you said everything it
makes sense to me welcome thank you yeah
this is really good at like it's really
you know like and by the way this is
what you'll have coz this is the
experienced version of the talent I had
I was sitting right there at 22 I was
working for my dad's liquor store
getting [ __ ] on by all my friends
parents and the whole world like you
[ __ ] suck so much that your job out
of college as you work in your dad's
liquor store and I was like keep talking
you understand it was all here I
understood right I was patient I did
what I had to do but what I didn't have
was 20 [ __ ] years of experience
you'll be talking just like this in 20
years experience matters I now
understand because I've tasted it
because I had to go through my own to
like feel it to be able to give it you
know
especially cuz you can help so many
people music is so powerful right like
all those stories and thoughts they need
to see the world you're being selfish I
know right so that's it you know take
this listen let's be friends I really
want to be friends you can't buy but I'm
gonna give it to alright give me a pen
I'm coming that'd be amazing no I can't
have you buy it it's not gonna go get me
some let's take a quick photo I gotta
take a call
alright I'll give you guys books you got
it right
without the book cuz I want to just mean
you me God thank you so much cool thank
you you're welcome
she's special she really is man she's
like gonna win let me help like you're
gonna win like for me like honestly you
know what's running through my mind
right now
straight up I'm like I am so happy I
have that on film cuz one day you're
gonna be the biggest star in the world
and I'm just gonna keep putting out the
clip when you're like wow he's the best
like just imagine on a very serious kick
imagine you at film of like you acting
that way but you were a 20 year old
Beyonce like that's what I think is
gonna happen you're welcome
that was incredible she was I really
like that meeting
[Music]